die krone lage in deutschland ist weiter
sehr ernst es kann kein anlass sein für
eine entwarnung im gegenteil sie
verstärkt sich die zahlen steigen weiter
an
und wir spüren überall in deutschland
neue höchstzahlen auch bayern hat hohe
entwicklungen hier liegen im vergleich
zum frühjahr in der relation natürlich
anders aber es trifft uns alle in
gleicher weise
bayern ist nicht mehr spitzenreiter aber
genauso schwer getroffen wir haben heute
eine infektions zahl von über 2.000
fällen allerdings auf einem stabil hohen
niveau der letzten tage
wir haben aber insgesamt zwölf
verstorben im vergleich zu gestern sind
dazugekommen
insgesamt sind wir jetzt bei drei
gebietskörperschaften über 200 incidents
wert wir haben insgesamt 32 über 155
über 50 das heißt es ist eine breite
struktur der inzidenz wert in bayern
liegt derzeit bei 92 dies ist in
deutschland platz sechs fuhren sind ein
anderer länder die einen höheren wert
haben dies alles ist aber kein anlass
zur entwarnung im gegenteil zu höchster
besorgnis die entwicklung ist eindeutig
sie verläuft seit wochen gleich auch
wenn die kurve in bayern sich etwas
abflacht ist es so dass wir davon
ausgehen müssen dass wir dieser tage
wieder dem nächsten sprünge erwarten
können auch in den krankenhäusern kommt
der korona zunehmend an weil vielleicht
zu den letzten drei wochen eine
steigerung 100 prozent der
entsprechenden belegten betten und es
wird mit den krankenhäusern ist nur eine
frage der zeit bis wir eine überlastung
haben nicht nur wegen den betten sondern
auch wegen dem entsprechenden
pflegepersonal
warum ist das bislang noch nicht so
angekommen zum glück sage ich zum glück
weil wir auch ein stück weit besser
vorbereitet seien als im frühjahr
die entsprechenden hygienemaßnahmen
wirken die entsprechenden masken
situation hilft sehr auch in den
altenpflegeheimen so dass die
zeitverzögerung zwischen der ansteckung
der verbreiterung der ansteckung und
auch der wirkungsweise medizinischen
sich gottseidank verlängert hat
insbesondere wir haben mehrere fälle
erlebt wo leute auch mit masken
angesteckt wurden aber bei den masken
und über masken ist die virenlast viel
geringer so dass die wahl
die krankheitsentwicklung deutlich
weniger ist trotzdem je mehr desto mehr
das kann man glaube ich so sagen das
heißt wir haben bislang und das kann man
sagen bei all denen die den letzten
wochen monaten skeptisch waren aber
corona überhaupt noch eine
herausforderung ist kann man sagen wir
haben das sage ich ausdrücklich leider
mit den einschätzung recht behalten in
deutschland aber auch in ganz europa wir
müssen jetzt aufpassen dass wir in
deutschland keine europäische
vergleichbare entwicklung haben
denn bei unseren partnerländern kann man
das eindeutig erkennen
dort haben wir zum teil extrem hohe zahl
dort haben wir überlastete krankenhäuser
und komplette lockt das die anstehen
deswegen muss jedem klar sein der größte
schaden für die wirtschaft ist eine
verschleppte situation
das ist das was auf dauer die
schwierigste
deswegen ist für uns wichtig dass wir
jetzt den risiken ins auge schauen und
vernünftig und klug damit umgehen
verzögern wird nicht helfen verschleppen
verschlimmert das ist wie bei jeder
anderen form von krankheiten wenn man
entweder zu früh aufsteht oder nicht die
richtige dosis an therapie macht kann es
sein dass die rückwirkung viel viel
höher ist da sind kommt es jetzt in den
nächsten tagen genau darauf an dass
entsprechende timing und tuning so
optimal wie möglich zu gestalten
dafür gibt es kein exaktes rechenexempel
dafür gibt es auch keinen genauen sprung
punkt aber das gespür dass wir bald vor
schwierigen entscheidungen stehen wächst
und zwar national wie in bayern wenden
derzeit ja die regionale hotspot
strategie an zwei landkreise haben sind
locker angegangen
während es auch in absprache ist das
geschehen mit der gesundheitsminister
die auch zum tarif ort war
ich halte es für richtig und konsequent
den jeweiligen land treten auch da die
rückendeckung zu geben warum weil die
inzidenz werde waren so hoch dass eine
unkontrollierte entwicklung zu erwarten
gewesen wäre
und anders als
in anderen bereichen hat man rechtzeitig
meinung nach reagiert die zahlen im
berchtesgadener land beginnen sich zu
stabilisieren sogar leicht zu sinken was
ein ganz gutes indiz für die entwicklung
entwicklung ist deswegen glaube ich kann
man nur eines am ende auch sagen
das einzige worauf man sich relativ
verlässlich einstellen muss bei kroner
ist lieber schneller und konsequenter
als verzögert und verlängert es gibt
unzählige statistiken die herangezogen
werden
aber letztlich geht es im kern und die
zahl die ich schon mehrfach genannt habe
die höhe der infektionen ab einem
bestimmten punkt ist so breit gestreut
dass ein reines zielgerichtetes arbeiten
fast nicht mehr möglich ist
deswegen wird morgen auch bei der
minister aber sinn -konferenz und das
ist schon wichtig wenn man donnerstag
übrigens auch wieder kabinett angemeldet
und einberufen um entsprechend
vielleicht dann auch anpassen zu können
der maßnahmen morgen bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist es
schon jetzt ein
wir sagen dass jedes mal aber das ist
jetzt wirklich ein ganz entscheidender
punkt wir haben nicht mehr viele
möglichkeiten einheitlich national zu
steuern
wir müssen schauen dass wir nicht immer
etwas beschließen was zwei wochen später
überholt ist
manche der maßnahmen hätten eine große
wirkung entfaltet wenn man sich früher
getroffen hätte aber maßnahmen haben
häufig eine halbwertzeit um die geringer
als wenn sie zu spät trifft ab einem
bestimmten punkt funktionieren einzelne
maßnahmen eine sperrstunde zu verringern
um ein zwei stunden ist zu beginn einer
entwicklung eine hilfs der hilfsmaßnahme
die funktionieren kann eine gute
hilfreiche maßnahme ab einem bestimmten
punkt hat sie eine dämpfende vielleicht
wirkung aber keine trendumkehr mehr und
wir müssen eine trendumkehr erreichen
wenn wir keine trendumkehr erreichen
wenn wir die zahl nicht wieder
grundlegend runter bekommen dann wird es
den ganzen winter mit schwerwiegenden
folgen für die wirtschaft aber auch für
die psyche und für die psychologische
wirkung für viele viele menschen haben
man spürt er jetzt schon ein hohes maß
an chrome müdigkeit
auch wenn auf der einen seite krone
müdigkeit steht steht auf der anderen
seite eine wachsende besorgnis und der
wunsch an den start
doch deutlich hat ein konsequenter
einzugreifen
wir müssen jetzt versuchen so breit
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert wie möglich
so breit gesellschaftlich akzeptiert wie
möglich und so therapeutisch wirksam wie
nötig eine entsprechenden kurs zu
definieren der überall in deutschland
gilt
und der jetzt auch übrigens von den
jeweils regionalen unterschieden aber
der bestimmten höhe der regionalen
infektionszahlen breitet sich auch von
dort aus weiter aus das heißt man kann
nicht allein nur abstimmen da von den
landkreis können sie auf dauer wenn die
gesamtzahl nach oben geht jedenfalls ist
der trend dahin leider stärker deswegen
klares ziel keine placebo maßnahmen die
richtige dosis und lieber konsequenter
und schneller
dann dauernd auch entsprechende
maßnahmen nicht so lange wir haben im
frühjahr erlebt was wirkt wir hatten den
wenig schwerwiegendsten lockdown in ganz
europa aber den wirksamsten mit fast
deswegen glaube ich muss uns allen klar
sein was möglich ist entscheidendes ziel
ist kontakte reduzieren kontakte
reduzieren kontakte reduzieren und das
virus somit einzudämmen
wo die meisten kontakte bestehen danach
gibt es keine exakt verlässliche
grundlage es gibt wohl
wahrscheinlichkeiten
die sind definiert das ist zum beispiel
im bei privaten feiern endlich mehr
aber es gibt bei jeder privaten feier
jemand der infiziert hinkommt und andere
infiziert und das sind gibt es auch da
leider auch keine sicherheit zu sagen
diese oder jene veranstaltung zumal auch
beim besten hygiene konzept es reicht
ein oder zwei die dann möglicherweise
gar nicht bös gemeint sich schwer tun
etwas einzuhalten und schon haben wir
die entwicklung umgekehrt gibt es sehr
negative entwicklung die ich heute
gelesen habe dass konzerte irgendwo
ausgewiesen werden wo man sich dann zum
freiwillig als infektions gruppe
definiert so was kann auf dauer kein
hilfreich ist konzept sagen deswegen es
nützt nichts zu schimpfen es nützt
nichts sich zu ärgern sondern wir müssen
das tun
was notwendig ist mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren